,
on suit de près les aléas
de l'économie américaine.
Si le Canada suit la même
d'une récession seraient
dévastatdévastatdévastateurs.
PHILIPPE HAMAN, directeur
général, La Distilleriesssssssss
des besoins essentiels de base.s
quand il y a des récessions.
- Les dernières annéesementées t
néanmoins permis de se préparer
aux nouvelles secousses.
- Le positif, on a déjà un plan,
notre plan en place en ayant
vécu les deux ans de pandémie.
Dès le début, on a fait un grand
ménage dans nos dépenses,
puis où est-ce qu'on mettait
les sous. avec un c avec un c as
bien garni, les enni, les enni,s
canadiennes se préparent leur ne
e décline au rythme
des prévisions économiques.
SIMON GAUDREAULT, Fédér. can.
- On arrive dans une situation
où il n'y a plus d'aide, i
de grosses dettes, il n'y a pas
des revenus normaux pourc'est qs
une espèce de traversée
du désert pour les PME.
- Hello, everyone!
- L'économie améri
un 2e trimestre consécutif,
avec un recul de 0B.
Mais la politique monétaire
américaine agressive, avec
des taux d'intérêts hier,
devrait suffir àsuffir àsuffir r
la récession selon Joe Biden.
- That doesn't sound
BENOÎT DUROCHER, économiste
principal, Mouvement Desjardins
- Évidemment, ces
répercussions chez nous,
a et au Québec,
avec une croissance économique
qui devrait ralentir de faço
- L'économie canadiennes'en sors
de l'emploi et du secteur
immobilier. Mais le scénario cre
mince combinée à une hausse
du coût de la vie,
fera des consommateurs
les principales visûr qu'on le e
sur le portefeuille,
mais on essaie de trouver
les économies quand il y en a.
des années, ça ne diminue pas.
Je ne sais pas à quel point
en sorte d'aider les citoyens.
- Dans ce contexte-là,
des deux côtés. On paye
plus che plus,
on est un peu pénalisé par
le ralentissement de l'économier
à savoir si les États-Unisentre,
avec ses conséquences
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Mon